the setting couldn't have been more
idyllic I really was euphoric thinking
what a wonderful day this was it's not
ever expecting that I was going to
encounter in Eastern diamondback
rattlesnake well I wanted to photograph
the light was right and I had my camera
with me I took several photographs of
the snake you know at that point that
should have been sufficient and I'll
never know why I decided I had to pick
the snake up nice Hey Bruce found a
stick to pin the snake's head what he
didn't realize was that sticks too short
he's dealing with a snake that doesn't
want to be examined and won't hesitate
to voice its displeasure if it senses an
opening and it does
at first the pain was nothing more than
a pinprick but the moment the venom
enters Bruce's bloodstream it begins
attacking his tissues and cells setting
off a chain reaction that could paralyze
his entire system
no one could clock his ticket Bruce
begins a frantic race to get back to
civilization he'll have to manage the
half-mile walk to the kayak and then
almost a mile paddle to get to the
mainland as I was going I was thinking
to myself I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna do it it's been nearly 20
minutes since the bike and Bruce knows
the Vipers venom can kill a man in as
little as an hour horizon you've got to
not panic don't think about how long a
paddle it will be to get to shore don't
think about you're all alone don't think
about you could die when I got ashore I
couldn't get out of the kayak
I was totally paralyzed from the lay
down you're trying to keep as low as you
can and you inch yourself along the
ground you know we are wiggling your
body back and forth and pulling with
your arms he's lost control of his lower
muscles
and the venom is close to paralyzing one
of his most critical organs his
diaphragm which will stop his breathing
his body is beginning its final
breakdown he's fighting for his life
his only hope is to make it to a
hospital with a supply of the right
anti-venom nearly an hour after being
bitten bruce lurches a mile down the
road to find help
and he does barely
but by the time he arrives at a hospital
he'll need 26 units of antivenom to save
his life
Bruce is extremely lucky to be alive the
bike easily could have killed him if he
hadn't stayed focused and calm despite
his close call Bruce is still chasing
down and studying these deadly creatures
constantly putting himself in the danger
zone when you put a transmitter in the
mouth and and gently massage it in the
stomach I got my fingers awfully close
to the working end so I've learned to
use a pair of forceps to manipulate this
all I gently slide it in there little
ways and she's feeling that there is a
bit of a danger even now for me working
with these animals I mean I love them I
empathize with them when I understand
them and you know familiarity in this
case drops my guard that's not good
you